in this chapter I used the rock layers
of the beach in which time essentially
runs sideways across the beach to
illustrate what the geologist Marsha
bjornerud calls time fullness
she writes I see that the events of the
past are still present this impression
is a glimpse not of timelessness but of
time fullness an acute consciousness of
how the world is made by indeed made of
time and trying to imagine whatever the
opposite of fungible time is I show the
reader these beach pebbles which happen
almost mid-paragraph like words and I
write look again at the Pebbles make no
mistake they are neither signs nor
symbols of time no they really are two
things at once sea floor from the last
ice age and Future Sand
so Beach or no beach simply making
everyday observations of what we
consider ecological or geological
reveals how intuitive this concrete
material sense of time Still Remains for
us and in fact I think this is exactly
what happened during the pandemic for
those whose scale of attention shrunk to
their house or their backyard
for example statistics involving birding
number of birding supplies sold number
of observations logged to sites like
eBird and visits to bird webcams show
that many more people became attentive
not only to the Daily movements of birds
but also their migrations Karina Newsome
an ornithologists and one of the
founders of blackbirders week noted that
spring migration coincided with the
early lockdowns and that it might be
therapeutic to watch the larger Rhythm
that continued to go on
in our Stillness other movements became
more palpable
for me one important clock ended up
being an individual buckeye tree in a
park that I always walk through
this tree grows leaves and flowers in
the spring and goes dormant in the late
summer but that procession is uneven
across the region across a Grove across
the branches of the same tree or across
the surface of a yellowing leaf
the body of the tree itself is also a
record of the past since the Buckeye's
ability to go dormant is an evolutionary
response to a change in the climate
three million years ago
and so I write what is a clock if it's
something that tells the time then my
Branch was a clock but unlike the clock
at home it would never return to its
original position
instead it was a physical witness and a
record of overlapping events some of
which happened long ago and some of
which are still occurring as I write
this
and that's that those images are also in
in the book this is also a text exchange
from last month when my boyfriend was
here and I was in the Santa Cruz
mountains and we're observing that the
clock is the same in both places
um Okay so
what I just described is something that
I describe in the book as unfreezing
something in time
oh
[Music]